[Music]
you're engaged you have a fiancee talk
to me about the proposal episode that's
the next one that we're gonna see um you
know what I always dreamed of doing a
proposal on Jersey Shore but for years
we didn't have Jersey Shore so when it
came back to the forefront everyone was
going I was like you know what I'm gonna
do it and finally I was able to do it my
best friends were all there we did it in
such a big way
I actually just see me in coming
attractions for it and it is so dope
I'm so excited for everyone to see it
and it's just really cool are you in
wedding planning mode right now
we are in the beginning steps what are
three wedding must have I just started
doing the cake testing okay and looking
at a number of venues and different
locations but so far the best you know
thing has been the cake testing so what
flavor cake do you put in it
um we're thinking of having two cakes oh
one for the wedding cake in one funfetti
cake for the girl you have to have the
funfetti it's our favorite yeah I gotta
have fun petty everyone loves funfetti
have you chosen a best man is it gonna
be someone in this room I haven't chosen
a best man yet but that day is coming
soon well that was like a yeah someone
said some of these guys down very soon
information yes it has to be there right
how do you guys feel about that
and we beyond to the rules the DJ and
the man are you gonna be having DJ the
wedding man is gonna be there I don't
expect him to DJ obviously yeah you
don't have to work at your wedding
exactly have fun yeah location you said
that you were looking at different but
we don't know if we're gonna be able to
give out their real estate yeah
will we see the wedding planning in the
season two can you mean we'll see
someone well we see other significant
others in season two do you think yeah
yeah
are we gonna get a televised wedding
you're working on it
I love that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]